well when I started it was totally not
totally print I mean I guess you tell
there was television as well but around
the time I started was a transition time
for the big magazine so look life
Saturday Evening Post Colliers all of
which eventually went out of business
presumably because television could
bring those sort of images to people
faster than and better more immediately
than they could although I sort of
missed life I like the idea that at the
end of the week whatever sort of grainy
picture you saw in the newspaper or
maybe one you hadn't seen in the
newspaper would be a full page in life
and you could actually see what happened
but all of these magazines sort of life
certain the one I saw closest up was
life because I was working for time then
in the Atlanta bureau may my and they
sort of flailed around trying to find
various ways to avoid what was really a
i clinical foregone conclusion one of
the things that I found I did a book of
some years ago on a college classmate of
mine who was a sort of golden boy who we
all expected to be President and life
had covered his his graduation and
Alfred Eisenstaedt photographs his
graduation and when I went back to look
at that issue of life I was surprised
because I hadn't remembered how many
just consumer ads there were almost
supermarket ads for for ketchup and
jello and things like that so that whole
business has changed and it's changing
again obviously the papers it doesn't
seem that long ago when papers were
thought of a sort of cash cows the
whatever I can't remember the wonderful
euphemism they had for the for the
legislation that made it possible
essentially to have a monopoly in the
city of something like failing newspaper
act or something like that it gave
people just sort of a license to print
money and even when they started to get
in trouble they got in trouble even
though they were making profits but but
Wall Street said they weren't enough and
then unfortunately many of them decided
that the way to save themselves was to
cut down on the service that they had so
they cut people who were who were doing
news stories cut particularly people who
were doing stories that took some time
and I think that's the part that's not
going to be replaced and I think I think
that's the really dangerous part even
though there's a sort of a inside
blogosphere kind of culture that the
leak stories and has whistleblowers and
everything the reporter spending weeks
or months on a story finding out
something I think is soon going to be a
thing of the past and and I mean the
statistics you read some paper i don't
know i think was the philadelphia
inquirer used to have this many people
covering city hall now they have that
many a tiny fraction of that so there
are their stories you're going to escape
those few people they can't possibly do
on me and then they can't spare those
people to to work weeks or months on the
story so I think that part's going to
change and I don't think it's I don't
think it's a good change
the last person to ask about that as a
reporter anybody on the editorial side
of journalism is usually the last to
know about anything I suspect that the
people when gourmet folded who were the
last people to know were the people
working there I the day it folded I had
a beautifully engraved thick invitation
to a party celebrating the editors tenth
year as the editor it's always done sort
of surprisingly I don't know I mean I
guess I guess somebody's going to figure
out how to make money out of the
internet and and I may be niche
magazines I think the people in in
trouble are often say for instance the
news magazines which it's hard to
remember the time was founded it was an
invention really time like The Reader's
Digest it was an invention and and the
idea was to cart compartmentalize the
news so that these busy executives some
could read it fast and in the beginning
they didn't even have reporters I mean
they just they just took from what they
got from newspapers and and the AP wire
and all that put it in a easy to read
fast format and invented actually some
coverage that otherwise wasn't really
being done right religion medicine
things like that the press and maybe 20
years ago time briefly had a motto or
advertising slogan make time for time in
other words the opposite of the original
intention of the magazine because time
was then considered than a long read
it's like sort of it became like make
room for Prust or something like that
compared to the
you know and you can you can actually
somebody somewhere probably in some
journalism school keeps track of the of
the sound bites of speeches run on
television and and they've shrunk over
the years so so this these magazines
that were really invented to save people
time now are considered sort of a burden
of to read so then they have to reinvent
themselves some way or go under
why don't feel good about it and I don't
think anybody the time it used to be
called church and state that you didn't
cross the line between church and state
although in fact you might argue that
they did sometimes cross the line at The
New Yorker one of the Fleischman's of
peter fleischmann i think was then the
owner of The New Yorker or the family
that owned the new yorker always said
that he never when he saw the editor in
the elevator or on the hall or ran into
him somewhere he never complimented him
on a piece because that would imply that
that there were pieces he he didn't like
or he did like and he thought it was
none of his business that he if he
didn't like what the other it was doing
he could hire another letter I think and
in those days for instance the New
Yorker never had a party there was an
annual anniversary party that we were
told was the business departments party
and we were invited to it but it was an
armed party you have a Christmas party
till the till the office voice finally
started throwing a party themselves
which we were invited to know and I may
be the management finally gave in and
sent the office voice of scotch or
something for their party but basically
we didn't have parties well now you have
I don't mean at the new yorker but in
general you have these people sponsoring
things having events that that are
really promotional things I mean there's
been in the last 15 or 20 years a lot of
blurring of or having you know I mean
there was there was a piece and in
columbia journalism review all 20 15
years ago probably showing how the
covers of Vanity Fair matched the
advertising of the fashion industry
and I this obviously not a good change
for four I mean from the point of view
of people like me
well part of that is is simply the way
that that the role of alcohols change in
our society you know if you look at Mad
Men the the series about advertising in
the early 60s that is indeed how people
used to drink and they weren't just
reporters who drink that way everybody
drank that we were talking about it the
other day I knew somebody from the army
might was my commanding colonel in the
Army who'd become a PR guy and he had
some story he just needed to hand me a
press release really we went to lunch in
head I don't know three or four martinis
in order to do this in order to make
this handoff that was quite common and
but that was true in the advertising
business it was true in practically
every is certainly in New York and Jimmy
Carter famously railed against the two
martini lunch or three-martini lunch I
can't remember because on the expense
accounts but that was very common and I
think on the other hand I would agree
with gay that that there was a
connection between reporters and alcohol
it's hard to remember but being a
reporter is only lately a respectable
occupation and and certainly in when I
was a boy I think I'm a newspaper
reporter maybe there were a few
exceptions like the White House good or
the Washington columnist for the new
york times or something but basically it
was thought of as a bunch of people and
sort of greasy suits with with folded up
paper with these thick pencils and had a
bottle in the lower left-hand drawer and
I remember a friend of mine saying once
in Washington this was early on and my
career as a reporter he had just spent a
lot of time calling somebody secretary
trying to find out what happened at some
that didn't make a whole lot of
difference and he knew the Secretary was
lying to him and he knew when he finally
got the guy on the phone he would lie to
him and he would know that he was lying
to him and he would know that he would
notice on him and he said this is a guy
who would you know had master's degree
from Berkeley and a bachelor's degree
from Yale and all that and he said is
this a job for a college graduate and
the answer really was not exactly the
this is only lately in the last say 30
years or so that then I think it's being
thought of as a respectable occupation
and there was a lot of drinking I think
there's less now simply because people
drink less or the or they drink
different things that don't seem to be
as potent as as the three martinis are
in the bottle in the in the drawer but I
think that's partly a societal change I
don't think it's just journalism however
I do agree that the people who go into
journalism now and there had been I
think there was a piece by Maureen Dowd
since she wrote it with somebody else I
can't remember who several years ago
called the Nerds on the bus or something
like that it was a reference to a famous
book among journalists called the boys
on the bus by Tim Krause which follow
the people who followed the presidential
campaign and and this piece was
basically about these are different guys
now these guys have been to Harvard and
they
they have little machines to do things
that that the old guys on the bus never
thought of and they and they have
families at almond and there and they
tend to stay married to them for a while
and and so they're they're they're a
different group of people then used to
be on the bus or or or covering things
and and I think probably tend to drink
less partly because of their Karen
partly because of who they are
well I mean I guess some of the most
dramatic were very early on when when
when I was in the south and spent a year
in the south and and I was on the bus
the freedom ride bus that went in the
first bus that went into jackson and and
some of the some of the i happen to be
in the south in a very busy time the
south the segregation story or
integration story worked on plateaus
because there were there was no real
pressure from Washington so not much it
happened in the six months before I got
there and but a lot happened in the year
I was there and there were two people
for time than in the southern bureau I
replaced a guy who I think had left six
or eight months before they're just we
hadn't been anybody and and the bureau
chief was married and had a few children
and and to my astonishment actually
preferred to stay home rather than go
chase by get chased by people with clubs
and terrible places I was delighted that
he would let me do that but but I
couldn't imagine why anybody would do
that I later learned that it was a more
sensible way to lead your life so I
guess I guess when I think of sort of
dramatic moments I I think of the south
I was totally surprised by its closing
and although I've written for gourmet
I'm not really I wasn't ever a reader
gourmet or of any other food magazine
i'm really not that interested in the
subject or actually not that not
interested in role in the subject of
food and cooking and and I don't cook so
so the recipes were not of any use to me
but but it was as people have been
saying since it the announcement was
made it really was a sort of an icon
gourmet and I ran into a chef I know in
my neighborhood yesterday and he just
said he was heartbroken by it it was it
was what they looked up to and I guess
bone Appetit I get the theory that I I
only know what I read in the papers that
the theory was that bone uppity all
owned by conde nast as well was a sort
of middlebrow version and there and and
that the decision was essentially
gourmet is is for the elite and this is
for the middle class and will go with
these sort of people who who like sort
of kind of meat and potatoes recipes and
need to cook at home and want to know
about various things and save money and
things okay um you know again it's one
of those financial decisions that for
people who are actually doing the riding
are always totally puzzling
since the advent of the computer I used
to do some very specific drafts starting
out with sort of a pre-draft that was
unfortunately referred to around the
house as the vomit out was when I got
home from some from the reporting I
would write a version of peace without
even looking at my notes i think when i
try to figure out what the purpose of
the vomit out was i think i think it was
to see what kind of inventory what was
in my mind and also see what wouldn't
work I mean which which direction the
piece had to go in or do or couldn't go
in and it started out in more or less
English but sort of disintegrated as I
went so I was always afraid when I wrote
more at The New Yorker instead of at
home I was always afraid that some
cleaning woman would find one of the
vomit outs and and entertain the other
cleaning woman by reading it and he'd
say oh he calls himself a writer and
they would slap their brooms against the
desks like hockey players and I would I
actually often didn't even look at it
after I did it the next day I would
start on them
for 15 years I did a piece of around the
country every three weeks for The New
Yorker and there was a day for each one
of these graphs and half of the rough
draft the next day it happened then
something called the yellow draft that
was different kind of paper and typing
up on the computer and when I first
started with the computer i started more
or less the same way i would i would i
used it as a fast typewriter i would i
would just print out the draft and then
start over again start actually typing
it over again over the years I finally
got weaned from that and and now i guess
the what the people who know about
computers would say is that i compose on
the computer more than i did before but
um so I I don't have any particular
ritual or anything like that I'm very
sorry I don't have a complicated ritual
I I always said no writer ever lost
money taking himself too seriously so I
wish I could tell you that I stood on my
head or something like I don't I just
write whatever I have to write
well you can erase
typewriter to in the sense that the
draft doesn't have to I used to just
take it out of the typewriter in and rip
the page and staple it on and then
staple the next place so so you can I'm
not so sure I used to think that the
writing on a computer encouraged kalixa
T because you could you could sort of
move whole sections instead of retyping
them and but i think by now everybody's
so accustomed the computers and my
thought process was pretty much tied to
the typewriter because I I grew up in
Kansas City and and you now occasionally
read about cities running out of money
in closing the schools but Kansas City
was away in the lead on this it ran out
of money when I was about an eighth
grade and closed the school and my
father thought the kids shouldn't be out
on the street in April or whatever it
was so she sent my sister and me to
Sarah Jean Hooley secretarial school and
then I we were I was I my sister was
liberated then which I doesn't I've
never understood that because usually in
that era I girls it was it was thought
that that was one of the skills that
would allow them to get work but I was
made to type every day for something so
consequently my my thoughts have always
been sort of connected to typing and
there was a time when if I had to write
something I'd oh thank you note in
longhand I'd have to type it out first
and then and then copy but um I I mean
that isn't true of a lot of people and
now everybody types even business people
type I think was Fran Lebowitz said
about men isn't an amazing how fast they
learned to type they used to say before
computers that you know they're big
fingers wouldn't work in all that and
they suddenly learned to type
Oh small matters like whether the boiler
guy is going to come and when he's
supposed to to get thing and i'm not
sure about i usually go to sleep and
then wake up and I'm thinking of these
things I'm not sure they wake me up at
but once i'm up I I I once I once gave a
talk not long after nine eleven in some
library people in Brooklyn I mean
friends of the library and Brooklyn
something like that and I someone said
are you concerned about flying after
nine eleven you fly a lot and I said
yeah what concerns me is you have to
show your ID so much I'm afraid I'll
lose my driver's license and you might
say I'm more afraid of the New York
State Department of Motor Vehicles than
I am of Arab terrorists and week or two
later I got a letter from somebody in
the audience who said she knew of a very
good psychiatrist who specialize in
people who worry about small matters
such as that and I thought said what
actually was a joke but but that
sometimes I think I could use that guy